so you said that you consider
transgenderism a mental disorder which
is something that I don't know enough
about to properly meet you on and
criticize so more broadly that then
brings me to ask do you think that the
United States should do more to develop
proper infrastructure to take care of
people generally who suffer from various
mental illnesses or are we doing a fine
job the answer is yes I think that the
the typical route of taking care of
people can't take care of themselves
more broadly and I don't believe by the
way that every form of mental illness
requires an entire system of
infrastructure right I don't think that
a transgender person is suffering the
same type of mental disorder as somebody
who has severe bipolar disorder for
example and my grandfather and my father
said my dad's debt suffered from either
manic depression or or actual
schizophrenia and had to be
institutionalized for a while that's
different thing than transgenderism for
example so the treatments are not the
same for every mental disorder of course
but the idea that people can't take care
of themselves need some sort of net is
is well-established in in sort of
American public life but I would suggest
that the place that you start is the
place that everyone starts when they
need help you start with the family if
the family can't help then you go to the
community and I mean generally the
religious and social community if that
can't help you go to local government if
that can't help state government if that
can't help federal government one of the
great tragedies of our mental illness
system is that it's been federalized so
it used to be that local and state
communities were largely responsible for
funding mental health facilities in the
1960s JFK because he had a sister who
was mentally ill thought that the
federal government could do a better job
and he actually imposed from above a
federal system in in terms of mental
illness and and how to take care of
people for mentally ill that actually
removed responsibility from state states
just through the burden onto the federal
government it's made facilities worse
the in in the 1970s there was a vast
release of people who are mentally ill
and probably shouldn't be on the streets
onto the streets that led to a
significant uptick for example in
homelessness a huge percentage of people
who are homeless across the nation are
people with severe mental illness who
need to be on drugs and are not being
given their drugs and are being told
that it's an aspect of freedom to live
on the streets and live in misery I
don't think that that's right at all so
my sure that that's my short answer as
to what we need to do with people who
can't take care of themselves